[Musique]
les 16 et 17 septembre prochains auront
lieu les journées européennes du
patrimoine placées cette année sous le
thème jeunesse et patrimoine en
conférence de presse les responsables et
des équipements culturels du département
ont présenté leur programme pour cet
événement le musée léon dierx inaugure
une nouvelle exposition sur les paysages
des eaux de l'île et la bibliothèque
départementale celle sur son opération
première page le département de la
réunion participe depuis sept ans déjà
l'opération nationale premières pages on
a souhaité cette année donner une
nouvelle dimension en proposant un
concours littéraire un concours de
création littéraire pour trouver l'album
qui sera offert à tous les bébés nés en
2016 ce concours a eu un énorme succès
puisqu'on a reçu plus de 112 manuscrit
nous avons donc souhaité proposer une
exposition de valorisation des
manuscrits issus du concours
voilà une scénographe nous aidera à
mettre en valeur ses manuscrits afin que
le grand public puisse découvrir la
production littéraire réunionnaise deux
jours riches en découvertes avec
notamment le lancement de l'application
numérique pour voyager et visiter le
musée historique de villèle et le site
de la chapelle pointue les visiteurs
sont invités effectivement apte à les
télécharger l'application qui est un
outil dead à la visite et découvrir les
différents parcours qui sont proposés et
qui s'adresse à tous types de publics
jeunes moins jeunes de personnes
empêchées personnes anglophones et
personnes créolophones le département
ouvre les portes de ses équipements
culturels au public et souhaite
intéresser plus particulièrement les
jeunes cette année une démarche de
valorisation et de découverte du
patrimoine qui se prolongent tout au
long de l'année grâce à des dispositifs
qui favorise l'accès des jeunes à la
culture
les jeunes peuvent venir avec des
médiateurs qui leur explique comment
comment fonctionnent les structures qui
leur fait découvrir tous les oeuvres qui
a dans les lieux qui leur expliquent
l'histoire des lieux
l'histoire de la réunion et on met aussi
la possibilité pour les écoles primaires
et les collèges
un moyen de transport pris en charge par
le département pour favoriser justement
justement les projets scolaires les
projets des collèges et faire en sorte
que les professeurs puissent amener
leurs enfants à découvrir ce patrimoine
historique de la réunion sur les
différents sites
[Musique]